[Music]
the wave of liveaction remakes continues
How to Train Your Dragon becomes a real
film with this film distributor
Paramount Pictures is following the
footsteps of its competitor Disney and
is trying to repeat the success of its
popular film series in our new original
we tell you everything about the
production the cast and the possible
plot of the Viking Adventure the How to
Train Your Dragon film series was an
all-around success the three films
generated worldwide box office takings
of over $1.6 billion and also received
several Academy Award nominations also
two series with the titles DreamWorks
Dragons and Dragons the nine Realms
followed 15 years after the start of the
film series a liveaction film adaptation
of the first part is now to follow in
2025 like the animated film The
live-action film adaptation will be
based on the similarly named children's
book currently it can be assumed that
the liveaction film will be based on
part one of the animated series The
Adventure film released in 2010 took us
into the world of the Vikings and told
the story of the weak but clever son of
the chief hiccup who lives in the Viking
Village of Burke this Village is
regularly attacked by dragons which in
the Viking world are considered as
Vermin and brutal monsters one day hiup
wants to prove to the village that he
also has the potential to be a strong
Viking and as a result of another attack
he shoots down a Night Fury this type of
dragon is considered particularly
dangerous however when he wants to check
the success of his shooting he finds out
that the Dragon toothless is by no means
a brutal monster but a lovely creature
from this point onwards an unusual
friendship develops between the two
which hiccup must keep secret from his
family hiccup will be played by
15-year-old actor Mason temps who
reached his Hollywood breakthrough with
the Apple TV plus series For All Mankind
and most recently starred alongside
Ethan Hawk in the Scott dson directed
horror film The Black phone at Tim side
will be Nico Parker the daughter of
well-known actress tandu Newton was
previously involved in the live action
adaptation of Dumbo and played the
daughter of Pedro Pascal's character
Joel in the acclaimed HBO series The
Last of Us in the How to Train Your
Dragon remake she will take on the role
of ASD the girl hiccup is in in love
with for casting caused some discussion
online as critical voices said the young
actress was not wi enough for the Viking
role it is not yet known who will play
the other popular roles for example the
role of hiccup's father sto the vast
however we can assume that in the
upcoming months we will steadily receive
more information about the cast of the
film as in the original film Dean de
blah will be the director and write the
script so the Remake should be in the
very best hands even if this is his very
first live-action film adaptation the
camera will be handled by none other
than Roger Deacons he is considered one
of the best known cinematographers in
Hollywood and received an Academy Award
for his work on denel new's science
fiction sequel Blade Runner 2049 and the
war film 1917 the filming was originally
scheduled to begin this summer but that
is now likely to be delayed for a while
the past actors and writers strike for
better working conditions paralyzed all
of Hollywood and with blocking numerous
productions for months whether the
announced us start of How to Train Your
Dragon on March 14th 2025 and thus be
kept will be revealed in the future if
the film ultimately proves to be a
success we can very likely expect new
adaptations of How to Train Your Dragon
2 and How to Train Your Dragon 3 The
Hidden World what do you think of
liveaction remakes are there any remakes
that would convince you or should
Classics like How to Train Your Dragon
be left as they are we're looking
forward to your opinion in the
[Music]
comments